yes welcome everyone to of us and to my
talk about securing backups with modern
platform security features today's talk
will be about a couple new features in
the web platform that you can actually
use to protect your occations and users
from common web vulnerabilities and my
name is Luca spikes laboum I'm an
information security engineer at Google
I work in the Zurich office and my team
is focusing on improving product
security by targeting proactive projects
with the aim of mitigating whole classes
of parts and today I will split the talk
into sections first a very quick run
through common web security flaws not
like explaining what they are but more
like looking at veer potater
and seeing which ones were common and
tried to categorize them and map them to
web platform security features and in
the second part we'll talk about is web
platform security features that are some
of them are super new actually we
probably not even have heard about them
yet but it would be super cool to start
a discussion about them maybe later
outside as well so let's start with two
security flaws Google has a VP program I
think for over eight years now and it's
not only a great source for you know
finding bugs and fixing them but it also
allows us to actually look at the root
causes and identify new classes of parks
and kind of try to get a feeling of
trends within these back classes right
so there's thousands of parks submitted
every year and in particular the web
application bugs are out of interest for
us if you look at the left side of the
chart you'll see that less than the half
is non web parks like you know server
side miss configuration or Android
applications will not focus about these
today will focus on the right side of
the chart which is slightly more than 50
percent and these are web Adamic box
right so
of course cross-site scripting is a big
offender in this space right and it's
still around and then there's other
things like cross-site request forgery
click checking and other web box which
we'll cover in a little bit more detail
in the later sections so the first big
category is of course injection bugs
right and I'm not going into detail
about what cross-site scripting is
because I assume most of you know the
only thing I want to mention is the
second type of process scripting
electron based XSS is actually becoming
more relevant these days because more
and more code is moving from the server
side to the client side and it's
actually quite easy for developers to
introduce non based XSS by accident and
it's on the other hand very hard for
security reviewers to spot these bugs in
code reviews right so that's cross
scripting and part of the talk will be
about to prevent and mitigate these bugs
but the larger part of the talk will be
about insufficient isolation and new web
platform features that help you to
address this category so the classical
example here is cross a request forgery
right and I'm not going into the detail
how that works but the very important
feature of it is that the server has not
enough information to actually tell
apart a request from your Lecter sites
or origin compared to a request that
originates from evil.com site right like
from a random origin on the Internet so
evil.com can put a form that looks
exactly the same on their side and have
JavaScript submit that form and for the
server since the browser will append
cookies to both requests these two
requests look exactly the same right and
one of the web platform mechanism we
want to present today is exactly about
this so and cross-site request forgery
is just one of these isolation related
issues
there's also cross-site leaks
timing attacks and lately also a couple
of new classes of vulnerabilities that
are have popped up that also fall into
this category of insufficient isolation
in the browser platform the most known
new one is probably Spectre which is a
micro architectural issue and yes so you
could say like this chart looks great
but it's maybe bit Google biased and
you're right
it's the data from our VRP so it's it
has a Google bias but if you look at
other ERP data for example from
hackathon you will see that they
actually see similar trends when it
comes to cross-site scripting cross-site
request forgery etc etcetera right so
this is still a big issue for industry
and also our friends at Mozilla report
similar statistics about these
vulnerabilities so what we want to do
now is to address these classes of parks
on in the web platform in the browser
right and there's a couple of new things
that have been already launched and are
coming up soon which I want to show you
today and as I mentioned we basically
have divided this up into two categories
isolation mechanisms and injection
defenses in the browser and in this talk
at OVAs I will mostly focus on the
isolation part mostly because of timing
reasons but if you want to see the full
fledged talk you can also get recording
from Google i/o and so let's start with
isolation so you might ask why do we
need isolation and the answer to that is
that because of certain issues in the
way the browser's isolate different
origins from each other
there is move abilities like cross
request forgery cross-site script
inclusion clickjacking web timing
attacks Specter they all fall into that
cut
and in particular into this subcategory
of attacks on resources so attacks and
resources are usually caused by the fact
that any site on the Internet can load a
resource from your server and your
server can not tell apart that resource
load from a resource load originating
from your own site right so there's
attacks on resources and the second
subcategory of isolation related attacks
are attacks on windows more specifically
on attacks based on like having a
reference to a window of a different
origin so the web is very open when it
comes to that regard and his site on the
Internet can open a new window and
navigate that window to your document
right or to your domain and that per se
is fine but by doing so that site will
still have a reference of in the
reference to your window and because of
that being the reference you can do a
couple of things that are may or may not
be surprising to you right for example
you can count frames in your site the
original window can also do some other
you know side channel attacks often used
in cross-site search the new cross had
search attacks they can do like tap
nabbing etc and especially for browsers
like Firefox that don't have a full side
isolation implemented yet it also means
that they cannot put the new window
document in a separate process and
protect you from Specter because of this
window reference so the second platform
mechanism I'll show in a bit will be
about that particular feature but before
we get into that a super quick review on
origins and sites I assume most of you
know what same-origin means but maybe
not everyone knows about the concept of
same site so same origin is basically
the tuple of
scheme host and port and whenever
two-year-olds
have the same values in these two poll
they're considered same origin for
example dr. dopler google.com /foo is
same origin to adaptive tabla cuckoo
combs - bark same site is similar but
different in the sense that neighboring
subdomains on the same retro
registerable domain would be considered
same site so mail.google.com and
photostat google.com would be considered
same site but not same origin and
basically everything else is just across
site and this distinction is very
important because based on that the
browser enforces different isolation
mechanisms on your side right and with
that we come to the first new web
platform feature to address the resource
isolation problem we showed you on the
first slide and it's actually quite
simple it is just free new request
headers set by the browser that
basically gives the server a chance to
are to reason about the context and the
source of an HTTP request
so implementation wise it's really
simple it's just free request headers
the first one is fetch site this is sent
by the browser for every request and it
basically just indicates the source of a
request right it just tells the server
this request was made like cross-site or
for example this request came from your
own site from the same origin and that
is extremely helpful for the server
because suddenly in the cross-site
request forgery in case the server can
actual reason and say oh wow this
request came from evil.com and not from
mysite.com so I may just want to block
it or strip cookies or do whatever with
it right you can have custom logic on
the server dealing with that information
the second header is sec fetch mode
indicating the type
of the request and most simply put this
means this header indicates if this was
like a resource load or if it was a
navigation and we'll see in a second
that this information is also quite
handy to protect on the server side
against a couple of web vulnerabilities
and the last header is sec fetch user
which basically informs the server if
the navigation was caused as a direct
consequence of a user interaction like a
click or a key press or if it was you
know JavaScript paste or something else
so let's look at a super simple example
for this on the top you see same origin
resource load sighted example loads file
from site dot example server and by that
the browser sends an additional request
header called sec fetch site with the
value same origin because it's the same
origin request and dessert the server
can say bill same origin requests are
allowed that's perfectly fine the
example below is actually a cross-site
request evil comm request something from
sighted example and by doing so the
user's browser will basically indicate
on the request that this request was
made across site because the host and of
the request and the actual source don't
match so that's still very simple and
simple information but you can actually
use these building blocks to build some
quite powerful server-side logic to
protect web applications against a
couple of common web application
security flaws and that example here is
a little bit simplified but this
basically prevents a couple of resource
isolation related issues and most
commonly known like it will
across that request forgery across the
script inclusion clickjacking and
similar issues right the logic is
actually easy the first condition just
checks if the sec fetch header request
header is available because if not it's
a browser that does not support this and
will just allow the request because we
don't want to break to the side for you
know users on all the browsers for
example but eventually when all the
browser's will support the feature this
like dis acuity will also be available
to two more users
the second condition is basically there
to ensure that all the same site or same
origin requests are allowed to proceed
right so if your site makes a request
for JavaScript or navigation or whatever
right the server will just normally
respond to it because it's the same
origin or same side navigation and the
third one basically ensures that cross
site navigation top-level navigation is
also allowed if you don't have the third
condition your site will basically be
siloed in the Internet
and no one can will be able to link to
your side right there's some use cases
for that as well but in the normal case
you still want other places to be able
to link to your site so you still would
allow top-level navigation even if it
happens across origin so everything else
is blocked what that means for example
if you have take the XSS I example if
evil comm loads a JavaScript from your
site and the browser sends cookies with
that request right your server will
basically block that request because
it's a cross-origin resource load and
you did not explicitly allow this here
so there's actually many many more
things you can do with fetch metadata
but this is like a trivial example how
to address resource like resource
isolation related issues with that
mechanic
usually you would roll out a fetch
metadata based protection in the form of
a middleware on the server side you
would start monitoring blocked requests
not actually blocking them and review
all the requests that actually got
blocked right because potentially your
application has endpoints that are meant
for cross-origin communication for
example if you have a course endpoint
that is meant for cross origin
communication and you would probably
want to whitelist that endpoint from
that logic to still allow that right and
if you've done if you if you have done
that you would switch to enforcement
mode and actually you know for example
block all requests that don't fulfill
this criteria or you can also do
something custom like you know stripping
cookies redirecting to the you know
entry side or doing other things right
and also very important to note here you
would also have to set a very header for
sec fetch site and sec fetch mode and
this also has a very nice side effect
that browsers will basically be forced
to have a per origin cache compared to
having a cache for all sites right and
implicitly by that you will prevent a
couple of excess search related issues
just by ensuring that stuff is not
cached across origins and so fetch
metadata shipping in chrome in the next
version in 76 but you can already play
with it by enabling the experimental
that platform features flag and yes
there's also already two projects on
github that provide a proof of concept
implementation for a resource isolation
based middle we're using fetch metadata
give it a try give us feedback and super
curious to hear hear what you think
about the approach and with that I'm
switching to
the next feature new feature which is
cross-origin opener policy and that in
particular addresses the isolation
issues related to window references the
second category
we had the slides before so what is this
about as we already said at the
beginning any site on the Internet
can open your site in a new window and
have a reference to that window and with
that reference they can you know they
can send post messages they can count
frames they may be leveraged other side
channels to you know learn about
something about your site for example
they could find out if the user is
logged in or not based on some things
and they can also navigate your site
away to an arbitrary other site and
there's a very easy way to prevent that
and that's the cross origin open a
policy response header you basically
second set this header to same origin or
same site and by that any cross site
page that opens your window we'll still
be able to open the window right but it
will not have the reference anymore and
by that it will not be able to navigate
your window on your side anymore and
especially nice the same site value can
be used if you for example have a cup of
subdomains and they you know communicate
through post message and you would still
a bone to allow that right so this
response header is quite new it's
already implemented in Firefox nightly
so we can try it chrome is working on it
but as of now I think there's nothing
implemented yet but we'll hope it will
come soon and and not a very nice side
effect of setting this response header
is that browsers like Firefox who don't
have a full side isolation to protect
against Specter will be able to put the
open window or you know the other domain
in the different browsing context
group which means the browser will be
able to separate the domains the origins
in with different processes right and by
that protecting against spectre like
attacks so especially for Firefox users
this header would be quite interesting
as well because I think it will take
some more time for Firefox to actually
natively implement a full side isolation
yes and with that I will do a couple
more slide on injection defenses there
is CSP which you can use to protect
against stored and reflected XSS and
partially dom-based XSS it's it was a
long long ride for CSP I don't know I
guess some of you have seen CSP and work
with CSP before and you have seen
policies like that
it's it's not great this type of
policies are super bad because they are
trivially by possible they are
incredibly hard to maintain without
breaking things and yeah they're just
not really worth your time right what we
would suggest instead is using a CSP
based analysis because it has two
critical advantage advantages and the
first is that this policy does not need
configuration or / endpoint or / site as
a matter of fact we use almost the same
policy across all Google applications
and the second thing is it's not
susceptible to the right list based CSP
PI passes which the previous policy and
the white list based policy would be so
we actually used this type of policy and
almost 60% of all outgoing Google text
HTML traffic and I think on over 100
domains and it was quite effective just
in the last 12 months it actually
blocked 20 high-risk XSS box and for us
that's very valuable time to actually
fix the bugs and
preventing them from being exploited so
I'm not going into the details how to
roll out this ESP based on ounces but
there is a nice write-up on CSP that
we've google.com that gives you a step
by step guide and how to do that and I
also strongly recommend if you already
have a CSP or if you diverge from the
template to actually use the CSP
evaluator because it actually is very
useful to spot common bypasses in a
policy that make it completely by
possible so whenever you have a red
exclamation mark in your policy you
might want to do something about it or
just delete the policy and yeah the TLDR
is the nice thing is is like always the
same except of the nonce which has to
change on every response it's definitely
better than widely spaced CSP and it's a
good mitigation against orden reflects
2x XSS and if the new CSP free strict
dynamic keyword you actually can use the
non-space CSP even in the case when
you'll have third-party JavaScript code
that loads resources right like payment
integration host using javascript from
Citians or widgets right in that case
earlier you couldn't use a nonce
only CSP but with strict dynamic you can
also now use a non space CSP in these
cases and here is a small peach for
another talk
there's also trusted types coming up in
the web platform and it's an amazing new
feature especially extremely well-suited
for preventing it against don't based
XSS and there's a talk by Christophe
Cote ovitch and Mike Samuel I think
after the lunch break and of course I
don't want to steal their thunder right
so you should so sorry whole c130
so you should totally check that out
it's one of my favorite favorite new web
platform features and what's really nice
about it is it also plays very well with
the classical CSP so you can set a
single policy with trusted types and
nonces and together the
very effective in actually preventing
and mitigating the vast majority of XSS
issues right so that should be your 2019
goal and yes with that I will wrap up
and basically you can now wake up again
I put everything on a single slides you
can take a photo and pretend you know
everything about these features now the
TLDR is that you can use CSP free for
reflected and stored XSS trusted types
for Dom based XSS fetch metadata request
terror to protect against isolation
issues that are based on resource loads
and you can use cross-origin open a
policy to protect your window references
from tampering and with that I wanted to
thank you for being here today the
slides are online as well and I put some
of the links also here just in case you
were not able to note them down
previously and I will hang around a bit
longer in case you have questions and
sorry okay even have some time for
questions if you are some so yeah
sure
so until the slide until the slide that
you have that it's clickable and it was
a get request clickable was it a fetch
metadata yes one second so was it that
slide you just passed it this one next
one
yeah yes so so the third condition why
does it have to be a get what so this is
mostly for a cross-site request forgery
protection so classical cross-site
request forgery case is a postmessage
cross origin and if you would for
example outpost here you would still be
able to protect it against XSS I and
other issues but post based cross-site
request forgery would not be protected
if you would allow post here and you
need to get because otherwise your site
would not be reachable from the internet
anymore so if you also prevent get then
any link from a cross origin domain
would not work because your server would
reject it what you could do is you can
redirect to the main page if you don't
want to allow gate as well but that's
already quite advanced but just use
cases for that basically we are only
allowing a get request clicked but if it
was a post request we are blocking it
yes if it's a cross origin post that
logic would block it if you have a
course endpoint or something that
actually is expected to receive post
requests cross origin you can have an
additional bite list to you know allow
these kind of requests okay thanks are
you working with the w3c for things like
fetch metadata to standardize the
headers because it's just in chrome you
know yes of course there is actually a
w3c spec for fetch metadata it just got
moved from my quests github repository
to w3c and I think just like there is
consensus that it makes sense chrome
already just already has the prototype
and others will follow some Oh
thank you thank you I wanted to ask
about the fetch metadata yeah I didn't
really understand if how does it improve
the security because in case an attacker
wants to for example send a get request
to some resource of another site I mean
it could maybe just I mean equal send an
AJAX request where he controls the
request headers and then it could change
the storage metadata
it's a sec metadata is has the sec
prefetch prefetch prefix right so you
cannot set this header through the
JavaScript API this is a protected
header by the browser only the browser
consent and set these headers so which
every brother's implement this
enforcement that you're not allowed to
set SEC headers I think all browsers
disallow setting certain headers and
that the SEC prefix prefix is one that
is I think protected in all browsers I
think there's also other headers request
headers that you cannot set in the
JavaScript API Explorer security reasons
sorry yeah sorry can you repeat that
what you said to refer a header you
cannot set an arbitrary valid a okay
thank you yeah and I think we're over
time already or no okay but also hang
around and that Felipe talk so
[Applause]